tras seis meses de investigaciones la
comisión parlamentaria de investigación
del senado concluyó que el presidente
bolsonaro cometió crímenes premeditados
en la gestión de la pandemia el informe
recomienda imputar 10 cargos entre los
que figuran crímenes contra la humanidad
uso inadecuado de los fondos públicos
incitación al crimen y prevaricación el
borrador inicial también incluía el
genocidio contra pueblos indígenas punto
que al final se excluyó de la causa
liderada por el senador progresista
renan calheiros quien recordó el dolor
de las víctimas
hoy no debemos hablar pero escuche a las
600 3.324 víctimas a través de estas
impactantes declaraciones en la cpi uno
de ellos dijo no superamos el duelo en
silencio hagan un informe que exprese lo
sucedido la investigación trata temas
como la falta de oxígeno en manaos los
retrasos en la compra de vacunas y los
discursos de bolsonaro en contra de los
confinamientos además de su escepticismo
desde el inicio de la pandemia del 19 y
de que aún sigue resistiéndose a
vacunarse
porque pasó aporte de vacunas yo quería
ver a santo jugar y ahora me dicen que
tengo que estar vacunado para poder ir
el partido tengo más anticuerpos que los
que se pusieron una vacuna
brasil suma más de 600.000 muertes por
el virus sólo por detrás de eeuu por lo
que ahora las víctimas piden
responsabilidades aunque nada garantiza
que la acusación prospere ya que tiene
que pasar por el fiscal general cercano
a bolsonaro por el momento tras la
publicación del veredicto final de la
cpi este será votado el próximo martes